you are going to meet people in your
life you do not like
they may not like you doesn't matter if
you have to decide i'm going to pursue
that path
which is going to be really really hard
and difficult and take many many years
and be a great sacrifice or am i going
to pursue
being a great employee
[Music]
okay chef wonderful here but not going
to be talking about cooking although i
am going to make some dinner i'm trying
to kill two birds with one stone
i want to answer some questions for ask
mr wonderful channel got lots of them
particularly around career
one of the suggestions made recently was
why don't you show your watch before you
start your channel
and i thought well do i really want to
do that and i thought yeah wait a minute
what is watchbuying all about anyways
let me explain why i have so many
watches
i support artists you don't need to make
watches anymore the best place to read
the time is on your phone it's
the most accurate you can get so why
would anybody build a watch make a
mechanical watch and today i am wearing
a sea dweller which is a big honking
rolex really a great weekend watch
a rubber band a rubber b band which is
red
rolex doesn't make red band for it so i
use this company called rubber b they're
not a sponsor i don't own any of them
but they do the best integration so i
use their bands just terrific
i'll do a little close up here you can
see it isn't that beautiful
fantastic watch anyways the point is
when you buy a watch
you're supporting an artist because they
spend their whole lives
from a young age learning how to do that
that's why i do it
on lots of watches support lots of
artists if i wasn't buying them and
others weren't buying them they wouldn't
make them anymore and that's a sad thing
that's a lost
art if you want a great watch go ahead
and buy one you're supporting somebody
just like you would if you're buying a
painting from an artist so anyways i'm
going to make salmon tonight love
cooking
and i'm going to do a mediterranean
salad with it
cucumber tomato lemon olive oil that's
it
salt and pepper very very very healthy
mediterranean diet very good for you
anyways let's get to business at hand i
get so many questions about career
talking about you know the stepping
stones of your career and everything let
me get out let me start with
my example i've talked i've told the
story before but i'll tell it again
there's a lot of lessons in it a lot of
things i learned you might be interested
in hearing
i'm in high school grade 11. there's
this girl in my class
i'm really hot for she works at a shoe
store in a mall
across from that shoe store it's an ice
cream store
and they're looking for somebody to be a
scooper and i'm figuring okay she's at
the shoe store
the whole mall closes at five that time
it was during the week
closed very early doesn't that's not the
way it is anymore but that's how it was
back then
and the idea was at five we would go out
and maybe cruise around a little bit
that was my plan
anyways so i sign up and i you know get
this job
and in ice cream stores still the same
today
if all these vats of ice cream people
come in they line up and they want to
get a little taster they know if they
want the chocolate they want the vanilla
whatever it is or the strawberry ripple
and so you give them a little wooden
spoon a little ice cream on it and then
they try it they sample it but often
they have gum in their mouths and they
throw it on the floor
before they sample right so my first day
i'm really excited i had a great day
scooping the woman who owns it comes
over and says listen before you leave
kevin
scrape all the gum off the floor we
don't want to stay in there overnight it
turns dark i went
what now i'm really worried because the
girl i'm hot for is looking at me
remember she's right across the mall
waiting for me to get out and now i'm
going to be on my knee scraping gum and
i said
no not going to do that
i am a scooper not a scraper
and she looked at me said no actually
you work for me
and you're going to do whatever i say
and right now i'm saying before you
leave
get on your bike you're scraping that
gum off the floor
and i said not doing that i'm thinking
i've got to hold the stand here
otherwise you know
we're not going to establish a working
relationship and she says okay how about
this
you're fired like whoa i'd never
it's one of my first jobs i'd never been
fired before it was very you know i
thought i said what do you mean i'm
fired she said
what it means is you're leaving here i'm
gonna pay her for one day and you're
gonna go home and tell your parents i
fired you
yeah that's what happened i was really
humiliated and it was an amazingly
difficult moment for me but it was a
crystal clear moment a very important
moment
this is the lesson learned you don't
know these things in life but at that
moment i realized there's two types of
people in the world
there's the people that own the store
and there's the people that
scrape the [ __ ] off the floor and you
kind of have to know which one you are
and i've said this many times before
there's no shame in being an employee
but it's not the same
as being an entrepreneur and that's the
lesson i want to talk about because
if you think about financial freedom in
the long run the only way you're going
to get that is take huge risk
what is that that's a definition of
entrepreneurship entrepreneurs do what
they do
95 of the time to pursue their own
destiny
and have control over their own lives
it's not the right path for everybody
i estimate that only a third of the
people out there
can do it now you may be in that group
and you may not be and there's no shame
in being an employee we're going to talk
about how to be a good employee too
but my point is that crystal clear
moment for me
happened and i realized years later that
i have a huge
debt to that woman in the ice cream
store and dave went back years later and
tried to find her with a camera crew
she was long gone so was the ice cream
store this is magoo's ice cream potter
this was magoo's ice cream parlor it was
my second day working there and the
owner had hired me to scoop ice cream
it was right here the counter was right
here
and i was finishing work one day and she
said to me
get down on your knees and scrape the
gum off the floor
right here it happened right here
changed my life forever
i have never ever in my life worked for
someone again
ever no one has ever had control over me
ever and never will but at that point
i was financially free i could afford to
bulldoze them all if i wanted to
just bulldoze it to the ground and in
fact that did happen to that mall and
somebody who heard the story before sent
me a piece of it
went out there in his car grabbed a
piece of the stone
and sent it to my office which is a
really nice thing to do because
and i use the story a lot to talk about
career
because you have to make that decision
for yourself you have to decide
i'm going to pursue that path which is
going to be really really hard
and difficult and take many many years
and be a great sacrifice or am i going
to pursue
being a great employee now if you want
to be a great employee you got to
remember something
you're hired to help someone else
achieve their goals which is cool
there's nothing wrong with it but if you
don't understand that you are not going
to be a good employee so
you have a boss and they say here's our
goal for the quarter you're going to
help me get there
you work like hell to make sure that
they achieve that goal you're part of
that team
that's very important and then you keep
moving up the ladder and the great thing
about that is if you're a good employee
you can also do very well it's not the
same as being an entrepreneur
you're never going to probably make as
much money as you could have
had you started the company is my point
but
you'll get the saturdays off the sundays
hang out go to the soccer games with the
kids
have a more balanced life there is no
balance in entrepreneurship
now one thing to remember about both
sides of this equation you are going to
meet people in your life you do not like
they may not like you doesn't matter the
point is
in work you're achieving results
towards a goal now you don't have to
love everybody you work with it's a nice
bonus but it's not going to happen
so you've got to kind of realize they
are stepping stones in your career they
are stepping stones if you're an
entrepreneur
they're they're points of resistance
they're roadblocks
they're they're you know pitfalls
they're
bumps whatever you want to call them but
you've got to
achieve success you've got to get over
them you've got to work with them
and you're going to move on if you dwell
on those if they
eat at you and they take away from your
focus
then you're losing and that's something
you have to learn
you have to learn to deal with the noise
people that don't like you people that
hassle you people you don't like
but that has nothing to do with
achieving the objective whatever that is
so if you own the business and you're
starting a company you know what you've
got to get done
number one you've got to take care of
your customers number two you've got to
take care of your employees and number
three your last on the list
take care of yourself you're always last
on the list when you're when you're when
you're an entrepreneur
you have to take everybody else and
along the way you're going to be
throwing all these challenges
they're potholes that's what they are
but i learned long ago from great
mentors that you got to deal with that
so think about that you also
learn things along the way that do not
seem important while you're learning
them but years later end up being
a really big deal let me explain one
that happened to me
and you could be learning something
today that you're just storing away and
is going to be very very important to
you down the road
which is why it's really important in
life to shut up and listen
a lot of people haven't figured that out
i have i know i'm talking to you right
now but
one of the things i've learned and the
more i more spend time i spend in
business the more this is important
more time i spent in life this is
important you should listen
two thirds of the day and talk one third
you learn a lot more you become more
powerful here's an example
my dad my stepdad was very influential
with me he basically said look you're
going to starve to death you've got to
go
to business school i go to do an mba
two-year course because my dad said you
don't know what you want to do so you
might as well just get some technical
training
which i did i got three months off i got
i got to find a gig summer gig
got a job at a company called nabisco
brands
okay they have a pet food division
miss mew cat food i get the job they're
working for a dutch
product manager very cool guy first day
on the job
takes me the rendering plant where they
make the basic pastes
that you make cat food with either you
make it with
sea of japan tuna the dark meat or you
make it with beef rendering and chicken
faces where they take beef lips
beef faces chicken faces render them
with papaya juice
crush them down make a paste and then
you add for example this is
good i'm here you take little celery
bits for example and you add it
to the paste so let's say you're putting
celery with um japan tuna and you call
that
tuna casserole now maybe you call it
tuna mediterranean salad whatever it is
you know bits of other stuff but it's
basically the paste
you have two things you got the sea
japan tuna you got the chicken faces the
beef renderings
they make up everything and all the rest
of the facings or market shares based on
the little add-ins you put into that cat
food
anyways i spent my three months working
on a new flavor my job was to launch a
new flavor
that september before i went back for my
second term
and um there's about a hundred salesmen
and women in the room and i have to
present the flavor
and the thing you got to know about cat
food is we had this this um
in upper vermont we had this place a
farm where we tested the cat food on
cats and i learned that
cats actually would prefer more water in
their food
but that's not an easy thing to sell to
people when they open the can it looks
like soup
they don't like it so you have to find
that balance between how much water is
in there
versus you know what the cats like
versus what the people like
so but i was a rookie and i didn't get
the joke
and the sales people did this every year
to the you know intern
and i'm telling him how great the flavor
is i think it's going to be a big hit in
the market
i can't remember whether i made it with
the cat food or with the sea in japan
tune i think i did
and they said yeah it's great kevin if
it's so good why don't you eat some
now it smelled like absolute [ __ ] and it
was soupy
towards the side the cats liked and i
looked at it went whoa
but you know i'm the rookie i didn't get
the joke so i did i put it on a cracker
and i ate it
and it was bad but cats like that i knew
that from the test
everybody roared with laughter they told
me it's the standard joke they do on
interns
but i get it you know and it worked and
i got a nice bonus
after those three months working there
but here's the thing
here's my revenge if you want to call it
that
years later now we're in software
we're at the learning company we're at
boston we're the world's largest
educational software company we make
software read a wrap at carmen san diego
may even speak and teaches typing or
argon trail you name it we make it
[Music]
we spend millions on r d but basically
in education
in our school system there's 110 000
schools all right the majority of them
in new york florida texas california
we sold to the school systems too and
what parents wanted what teachers wanted
and what students ultimately needed was
to advance their reading
and math scores reading math see japan
tuna
chicken faces all of a sudden i'm
sitting at lunch and i'm talking to the
guys and we're thinking about next year
and the millions we're going to spend on
r d i said guys
let me tell you this story about cat
food i said if we're
really just doing reading and math
titles and throwing in
bacon bits in the form of another
character big bird or reader rabbit or
carmen san diego or mavis speak can
teach his typing whatever it is
he's just a character but the basic code
is reading and math
why don't we consolidate down to two
engines save millions in r d
just have two teams and some graphic
artists that put in the characters on
top the kids don't care they're four to
seven years old
i'm not saying kids are cats but you
know what i'm saying
we saved millions that next year
where our cost of capital went way down
and we acquired all our competitors
where'd that come from that was the
lesson the dutch guy
taught me in the cat food business
my whole point is you don't know when
you're learning a lesson so shut up and
listen
you'll learn something and just file it
away and then one day
ichi you're going to pull it out of the
your brain's file folder and say here's
i'm going to solve that problem i guess
they call it experience
but i'll never forget that story
absolutely
incredible i mean
thank you dutch guy thank you miss new
cat food
hey that's how it works my whole life my
whole point about this is
your career is serendipitous you don't
know what's going to happen
spend more time listening realize you're
going to have to work with a lot of
[ __ ] that's okay
doesn't matter stay focused on the goal
of hand whether you're an employee
or not and you will find your path
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe